thanks to zenna
and thanks everyone for coming um
like susanna said i'm a software
developer on jax
and i'm super excited to kick off these
talks for the community week
and get you started with jax on cloud
tpus
so this talk is mostly going to consist
of a demo
go going over some jax basics running on
a cloud tpu vm
and this might be a terrible idea but
i'm gonna try to set up this demo
completely from scratch
to hopefully show you uh just how easy
it is to get started
with jaxx on tbu so wish me luck
um so with that i'm actually going to
dive right
in and create a demo vm
that we can use so we can have that
starting while we go over some slides
so i'm going to switch over to my gcp
dashboard
and go into the compute engine tpus tab
and then i already have some tpus
running but i'm going to create a new
one for this demo by hitting create tpu
node
um that filled load great
this is how you know it's a live demo
great so i am going to call this demo vm
pick my favorite zone us central 1a
we are going to opt into the new tpa tpu
vm
architecture i'll talk more about this
in a minute um
we are going to stick to a modest eight
uh
tpu cores v3 tpu cores
and pick v2 alpha this is always what
you choose when creating a
jaxx tpu vm so let's get that
creating okay sometimes this takes a
minute or two
so i am gonna in the meanwhile switch
over
to some slides and give you some basics
on tpus um and how you can use them with
jax
so to start um just in case you're not
familiar
what are cloud tpus so pictured here
is a single tpu v3 board
and the board has four individual chips
on it
and each tpu chip has two cores
each for a total of eight tpu cores
and then this board is just plugged into
a regular cpu host
very similarly to how you might plug a
gpu into a machine
um so what makes the cloud tpu system
special and more than just a box with
some chips attached to it
are the two key features you can see on
this slide
so the first key feature is a high speed
interconnects
which are basically high band with
communication links between the cores
so the cores can talk directly to each
other without going through the host
um and the second is basically the
power of compilers so tpus were designed
to be targeted by
a compiler specifically by the xla
compiler
so if you compare this to other
platforms that rely
more on uh pre-compiled kernels
that are invoked in something more like
an interpreter loop
um when you run on a tpu everything is
compiled
and this lets us drive the tpu cores
more effectively
okay so what makes cloud tpus or tpus in
general
really cool is that they're also
designed to be scaled
out into a tpu pod supercomputer
so now instead of just four chips on a
single board
a cloud tpu pod is 1024 chips
for a total of 2048 cores attached to
hundreds of cpu hosts um and
this is really scalable because we have
those same two key features
so the same high-speed interconnects
that connected those four
chips now connect all the chips in the
entire pod
uh and similarly the xla compiler can
also scale
to cover this entire pod so you can use
xla to compile for a single core a
single board
or the entire pod or anything in between
okay so what are these two
key features actually get you um
so with the high speed interconnects you
basically get
easy communication scaling uh you don't
need to worry
about the data center network topology
everything kind of just works
as you scale it out um and with the
compiler magic
you get a ton of cool compiler
optimizations
uh a few of which are listed here but
there are many more i'm sure
um uh but another cool thing about using
a compiler-based system
for research in particular is that
often when you're doing research you're
writing new code or new algorithms
that no one has ever tried before that's
what makes it research
so there's probably not an efficient
handwritten kernel
for all of the things you're trying to
do
so instead of writing your own kernel or
maybe waiting for someone else to catch
on and write a kernel
you can let the compiler do that work
for you and all the code you write can
be optimized
and super efficient
okay so we think that jax
is a particularly good fit for tpus
because jax itself is compiler oriented
um and this means that jax was designed
from the ground up around the xla
compiler and then you know xla was
designed around tpus so
jackson tpus are a good fit um
the implications of being compiler
oriented is that a few things listed
here
the first is that all operations
uh run through the compiler so you
always get
that compilation benefit everything you
do in jax um so besides the nice
performance benefit of this another nice
feature which is the second bullet point
is that um all jack's code can be run
on cpu
or tpu with no code changes
just by targeting different platforms
using xla
uh so there are a few exceptions to this
edge compiler features that just haven't
been implemented on all platforms yet
but so this is more of a implementation
issue than a fundamental design
or api issue and then finally
being compiler oriented means that you
have full control over the compiler
so we'll see more of this in the demo
but basically jax gives you a direct
interface to what's compiled
all wrapped up in a nice easy to use
python package
okay so just to give a little
quantitative evidence
for jackson tpus being a good match uh
here are some benchmark results from
last year
so these are from the mlperf benchmark
which is an industry standard
benchmark competition and it's designed
to fairly compare the performance of
different
ml hardware and software systems uh with
everyone
on equal footing because everyone's
running the same models
uh on the same data sets to the same
accuracy
so you can see in these charts that jax
on tpus is very competitive i believe we
set a few world records which was really
exciting
um and i don't want to get into too much
detail here but one thing you might note
is that
we're not comparing equal number of
chips in every column
so for example down here in the in the
bert section
uh jax is running on about four thousand
chips and pi torch is running on about
two thousand a one hundreds
so what's going on here is that we're
comparing the
largest and fastest submissions from
each platform
so these results actually demonstrate
the two advantages
of tpus that we mentioned earlier uh
basically the specialized high speed
interconnect
allows the tpu submissions to scale
usefully to more chips
and then the xla compiler let us squeeze
as much performance as possible
out of each chip um even though the tpu
v3 is
actually released i think like two years
before the a100 so that's how we were
able to get
running so fast on so many chips
um oh something i forgot to mention so
these numbers
were produced on internal google tpus
not on cloud tpus
so this is like the same chips but with
different software on top
um and until recently there wasn't
a way to access cloud tpus in a way that
you could reasonably run
a high performance workload like this
but luckily
now you can um enter cloud tpu vms
so this is basically a new way to access
cloud tpus where you have a vm running
directly
on the tpu host so this makes things
pretty simple
because you just have ssh access to the
tpu host vm
and you can run anything you want like
jack's code
you can also run pytorch or tensorflow
uh random python code c plus plus
whatever it's really just a regular vm
that happens to have
some gpus attached to it
um and then here's just a picture
showing that of course the skills
up to pods um in this case when you're
running on a pod or a pod slice which is
a subset of a pod
you just have more hosts and so that's
more vms
that you connect to but again you can
run whatever you want on these pod
vms um
okay so this is the final slide before
we uh hopefully get the demo working
and i just wanted to give a very quick
overview of what jax looks like before
diving into the demo
so here's an example of some jax code
and if you've used numpy before this
might look familiar
so here in the middle we're defining a
kind of fully little fully connected
neural net
and we have a matching loss function and
so
the difference is that instead of using
numpy we're using jax dot numpy
uh which we're going to call jnp and so
what this gets you is that um like i
said jax was built directly on top of
the xla compiler
and so all of this numpy code or jack's
numpy code
runs directly on an accelerator
so a gpu a tpu or on cpu
if you don't have access to an
accelerator or prototyping on your
laptop or something like that
um so out of the box we get accelerated
numpy but
at the bottom here you can also see we
have some
function transformations uh so i'm going
to go over these in detail in the demo
but just to give you a taste we're going
to do some things like
taking gradients doing some just-in-time
compilation
uh doing a vmap whatever that is
uh okay so with that let's
jump back and see how our demo vm is
doing it looks like it's up
okay now i have to do a complicated
operation where i switch
to a terminal window so let me stop
sharing this
let me create a new terminal
bear with me
okay um someone yell if you cannot see
this terminal
so uh i'm gonna i have some of these
rewritten but hopefully these commands
will make sense
um hopefully everyone can read this
so first we're going to use the gcloud
command to
ssh into the new demo vm we created and
the interesting thing here
is i'm going to add this is a standard
ssh
flag to set up port forwarding so that
um
i'm going to start a jupiter notebook on
the tpu vm and i want to be able to load
that notebook on my laptop
so i found the easiest way to do this is
with port forwarding
so
gcloud is nice because it automatically
sets up all your keys for you
okay so now we are running on the tpu vm
next i'm going to install jaxx
so if you've used jax before we've
actually recently updated our install
command
so this is pulling in all the
dependencies you need
including jack slip so once this
finishes
we should be all set up to use jacks
next i'm going to set up the demo
notebook so this
uh is still in my jack's fork on github
i promise i will check this in
um but for now we're going to be looking
at my fork
and then let's install a few
dependencies to actually run
a jupiter notebook and we'll do some
plotting
[Music]
okay it's complaining that these new
notebook binaries are not on our path so
i'm going to put that on my path
and then finally hopefully this works
let's start our jupiter notebook
great i'm gonna open that
okay let me switch back to that window
one second
i think it's this one
okay hopefully everyone can see i'm in
my jupiter notebook now
um and so i am going to open
the notebook i prepared
awesome okay so hopefully this works i
think i'm gonna have to move pretty fast
but to start we're just gonna go over um
jacks as accelerated numpy so i'm gonna
import jacks.numpy as jmp just like the
slide
and i'm gonna create a 5000 by 5000
matrix
x so this thing should act just like
regular numpy i can run
operations i can slice i can print
values
but if we take a closer look we see this
is not in fact a regular numpy
array but a device array so what this
means is that
this value is stored in device memory so
in this case uh in tpu core memory on my
tpu vm
and all the operations we run run on tpu
so the dot the slice
everything happens on the tpu and we
only bring the value back to the host
if we need to print it or write it to
disk or something like that
but other than that
definitely thank you thank you how's
that
looks good thank you okay so
other uh we have a device array but we
can treat it just like a regular numpy
array so we can plot it
uh matplotlib is a little bit slow uh we
can run more operations we can do fancy
numpy indexing
uh so to demonstrate that this truly is
running on my tpu vm
i'm going to do a quick micro benchmark
where i'm going to create the same array
as a regular numpy array uh and we can
time a dot product and we see it runs
about
153 milliseconds per dot operation
not bad for numpy but if we run the same
benchmark
using jmp.dot with our device array
we see that it runs much faster
just under six milliseconds per dot
product
so turns out tpus are pretty good at
this
um okay so this gives us numpy running
on our cloud tpu vm so that's already
pretty cool
but let's dive in to those jacks uh
function transformations that we saw in
the slide
so the first transformation i'm gonna go
over is automatic differentiation
uh jax supports a lot of different types
of ad
but i'm just gonna focus on your kind of
bread and butter reverse mode ad
which in jax is called grad so here is
a little toy function f that we can play
with and differentiate so we have some
control flow
doing some operations and
this is how we take the gradient of f
in jax so all function transformations
in jacks
have a similar api where the
transform takes a function as input
and then returns a new function as
output so in this case we pass in f as
input
and then this returns the gradient
function
of f as output so if we apply the
gradient function to some value
we get the gradient value out and what's
cool
about this kind of uh function transform
api
is that it's composable meaning that you
can
take the output of one function
transform and
pass it right back in to another
function transform as input
so this is how we're going to achieve
higher order
uh gradients in jacks we just take the
output
of that first grad call which is the
first order gradient
and pass it right back into grad to get
the second order gradient which we can
then apply to a value
and so on and so forth for higher order
gradients
uh okay so this is all i'm going to go
over for grad but we're really just
scratching the surface here
jax supports a number of other types of
ad
and you can learn all about this in the
jack's auto diff cookbook
in our documentation so the next
transform i'd like to go over
is called jit for just in time
compilation
so remember that everything so far has
been running
on the tpu and running with xla
but we've only been uh
running a single operation at a time
that's kind of how jax works by default
uh we call this up by op mode also
called eager mode
um jet lets us take full advantage
of xla which is like this really awesome
full program optimizing compiler
by staging out entire functions to
compile with xla instead of just one
tiny operation at a time so let's see
how this looks
um so here's another toy function
that we can try to compile uh so we're
gonna call this f
of course we can run f uh just as is we
get some values out uh but this is
running in up by op mode
so now let's make a new function g um
that's gonna be the jitted version of f
and so uh jit has a similar api to grad
where it takes a function in
and returns a new function out but this
time instead of
changing what the function computes it's
going to change
how the function is executed so you can
see that g of x
if you kind of match up these numbers
produces the same value
as f x but what's different about it is
that g
of x is going to stage out this whole
function and compile the entire function
using xla so in order to see this
let's do another micro benchmark so
first we're going to time
f x which is the op by op non-compiled
mode
get about 21 milliseconds per iteration
so if we look at g of x
i think it's running it like a million
times
okay yeah so order uh over an order of
magnitude
faster when running the compiled version
so that's a really nice speed up in this
case um
just to give you an idea of the kinds of
things that xla can do in order to get
this speed up
um one thing is it can fuse operations
together
so instead of each of these being a
separate op that we dispatch it's all
one big operator and then we're only
returning
a slice of the output in this example
and so xla
is smart enough to not even do the work
it doesn't need to do
in order to produce this output plus a
bunch of other optimizations
um so uh jit is also composable
uh so here we have jit and grad composed
many times it works just fine
um this is kind of a silly example in
real life you wouldn't actually call jit
twice like this on the same function
um like you don't get twice the speed up
by calling jit twice
but this kind of composability does come
in handy
uh for instance when you're writing
library code you can
functions in your library and then users
can just call those functions however
they want they can call grad they can
call jit uh
on top of it it's all fine and it also
becomes more interesting when you have
more bits of code in between these
different uh composed transforms
okay hopefully so far so good um i'm
going to move on
to the next transform which is called
vmap
so this one might be less familiar um
but it's actually pretty simple
hopefully
um we map is very similar
to a python map so you can see we pass a
function as input
and we're going to get a function as
output as usual
and how this works is that the output
function
so say that this lambda here takes a
scalar we'll call this a scalar function
the output function is going to take a
whole
vector of inputs and then
run this square function on each element
of the input so it's basically mapping
over the input and applying
this function uh that's what the v
mapped function does
um okay so we could have done this
you know with like a python map or
probably a for loop why
use vmap and what's interesting is the
way
that vmap achieves this mapped result
and it does it via vectorization
thus vmap meaning that it's going to
take
all the operations in the input function
and turn them into vectorized versions
of the same operations another way to
think about this
is that vmap adds a batch dimension
to your function and so it turns this
single example function into a
batched function um so in order to try
to see this
i am going to use another transform
called
make jack spur and make jack spur
basically gives
us a view of the input function
as jax sees it so the details aren't
super important here but the idea is
that if we call make jack spur
on dot and then pass it to vectors so
this is going to be a vector vector dot
you can see we get this one dot general
operation out and the details aren't
super important but like basically this
tells you that it's a vector vector dot
but this kind of operation can do lots
of different
dot like things um okay
so now let's look at the jack spur for
v map of dot and since we're adding
that new mapped dimension we're going to
pass into matrices instead of two
vectors
uh but we can see that the v vmwrapped
operation is still just a
single dot general so this is basically
going to be a matrix matrix dot instead
of a vector vector dot
and we efficiently do this in a single
operation
and so on and so forth we can keep
calling vmap
each time it's going to add a new
dimension to our input
but we still just get this single dot
general
operation um so
that's all i'm going to say about vmap
but uh this is a very toy example you
can imagine
um you know when you plug this into a
bigger function uh it can save you a lot
of time and
simplify your code by uh automatically
adding all these vectorized operations
okay um the next transform i'm going to
go over
is called pmap um
and so like i said everything so far has
been running on the tpu
but we've only been running on a single
tpu core so by default all jax code runs
on a single device in this case a single
core
um but like we saw in the slides a
tpu vm actually comes with an entire
board with h cores total so if we look
at jacks.devices
we can actually see we have eight tpu
devices
available to us on our vm so how do we
take full advantage of all eight tpu
cores here
um that's where we can use pmap so
pmap as the name implies
is very similar to vmap in fact it has
exactly the same api
so we pass the function in and we get
a mapped or batched version of the
function
out the difference is
how pmap computes that
mapped result so if we take a look at
the result
um what's going on here is that
pmap instead of vectorizing is going to
parallelize
so we take this function that we want to
map
and it's going to split up the input and
send
each element to a different tpu core
and each tpu core will compute its
result
over uh its slice of the input
and then so our output is this thing
called a
sharded device array so what this means
is that each of these output
elements is stored on a different
tpu core um but this thing otherwise
acts just like a regular numpy array or
just like a device array
so we can run some operations on it
it works just fine um one thing i want
to go over that trips people up a lot
is that we have this started device very
y that came out of our pmap
um and we can just run normal numpy
operations on it
but as soon as we start running
outside of a pmap we're gonna go back to
that single core
execution mode so you can see the output
of this operation is a device array
again because basically what happened
is it collected all these values back
onto a single core
in order to um do the division operation
so basically the rule is that any
operations
by default um are happening on a single
core
unless they're happening in a pmap and
then that's how you know
if it's running parallelized or single
core
okay um but going back to the sharded
device array
this kind of is similar to the device
array and that
because we're storing these values uh
sharded across multiple cores
we can avoid communication and only do
the minimum amount of communication and
work needed
and we do this by stringing together
many p-mapped operations or
alternatively you can just p-map a
larger function but just for the points
of demonstration let's take a look at
this example
so what we're doing here is using pmap
to
create a 5000 by 5000 matrix
on each tpu core so we're going to get
eight
matrices total stored as a sharded
device array
we can then um perform a parallelized
dot
to dot each each matrix with itself so
this is each core
is going to individually do a dot uh
we can then take a mean of the result on
each core
again using pmap and then print
the total result of this mean so the
only communication that happens here
is sending the final
mean back to the host for printing
otherwise everything happens
independently
on each core and we can try to see this
via a micro benchmark
so here i'm just going to do the single
device dot
this is similar to what we did earlier
so yeah just under 6 milliseconds
per dot and so now if we do eight dots
in parallel using pmap
um you can see that there's only a
slight
overhead to doing the eight dots but
certainly much
much better than eight times the single
device version
okay so that tells us how to do
work on each tpu core
but like i mentioned we have these
special high-speed interconnects that
allow the cores to talk directly to each
other
so how do we take advantage of that in
jax
um that's where these collective
communication
operations come in so we model this in
jacks
with collectives and what collectives
basically do
is let you break the map abstraction
and do an operation across
the mapped axis that you're adding with
pmap
so the simplest example of this is p sum
um as the name implies this is going to
do
a sum across all of the
cores across all that mapped axis that
pmap is adding
so to give an example of this here's a
function
where um remember so this x is the input
to
each uh each core each slice of the map
and we are going to compute a normalized
version of x by um summing together all
the x's
across all the mapped axis and then
dividing each individual
input by this total and i'm also
returning the total so that we can see
what this looks like
um so you can see here that we get all
our normalized values
out and then the total itself is going
to be
um each core gets its own copy of the
total so that's why we get
uh eight copies of the total here
um okay uh so you might notice this axis
name
um this is basically when we like pmap
is adding a new batch access is one way
to think about it
we can give a name to that axis and then
when we do a collective operation
we specify that name to say which axis
we want to do that operation over and so
this is not very interesting when
there's only one pmap and one
axis name but it gets more interesting
when you have multiple pmaps
with multiple axis names so i want to
make sure we have time for questions now
so i'm not going to go over this
in detail but basically you can specify
different axis names
in order to do different um
individual sums like we can sum across
rows or some
across columns or sum everything
all right i have one more transform that
i wanted to go over before ending this
talk
so i really don't have time to go over
this detail i think
but i'm gonna try to go over it really
fast and still leave time for questions
so this is a new experimental transform
meaning that we're still working on it
it might change as we develop it
but i thought it might be interesting to
take a look and see what it can do
so this is called pgit and pj
is another way to take advantage of
multiple devices and parallelize across
devices
um but instead of
it basically takes another view of the
computation than
pmap does so pmap kind of takes a
per device view of the computation like
we specify the function that we want to
run on each device
and then manually include collective
operations
when we want there to be communication
between devices
pget you give it a global view of the
computation like the computation you
want to run across
all devices and it automatically splits
it up
across the devices and adds
communication as necessary
so for an example we can do a
convolution operator
um so this might be useful
say you're doing a convolutional neural
net and you want to feed it
image examples that are so large that a
single example doesn't even fit on a
single device
you can use pj to automatically
split up that convolutional net
uh and run across multiple devices
so here we're just going to focus on the
conf operator
here i give an example that is very
small and does fit on one device
so we can see that that works just fine
with pgit it works somewhat similarly
to jit so like instead of doing a map
it's more like jet
where we pass in our function that we
want a pj
and we get a parallel version of the
same
function out so um
this should ideally get the same
response
or sorry the same result just like jit
but
um it's actually running a parallel
version that runs across multiple
devices so you can see in our micro
benchmark
this is running the single core conf in
about
45 milliseconds and then when we use
the pgitted parallel version of khan we
get
about a 5x speed up so that's pretty
good
for running across eight devices and uh
you get 5x instead of 8x because there
is some communication overhead so you
can't get perfect scaling
um okay yeah i'm not going to go over
the details
of how to actually invoke pget but
if you are interested to learn more
about that um
yeah maybe ask a question in the slack
channel or hit me up later i'd love to
talk more about it
um so with that that's all i have
prepared
and i would love to stop now for
questions thanks very much for listening
thanks so much sky super interesting we
had
a lot of good questions and discussion
in the chat
if you want to you can keep your slides
on maybe we'll go
back and forth we have just a few
minutes um
i just want to let everybody know in
case and we're probably not going to go
through
all of the questions um due to time
constraints but feel free to
also send slack uh send questions um to
slack
um okay let's start with maybe from the
beginning
while you're working on gcp can the same
be run can the same project be run on
kaggle tpu or google tpus or
does it require some different uh
installation of libraries
okay that's a good question sorry i'm
like way behind in a chat so i can't
actually know myself because i can't um
uh so
like i mentioned tpu vms are like a new
tpu
architecture that was recently released
um
some platforms in particular collab
and i think also kaggle which i think
uses a similar notebook setup
to collab um are still on the old
architecture
so you can still use jacks with these um
but you're not gonna get um
as like there's some performance
overheads and usability issues uh
i didn't go over the details between the
two architectures but so just to be
aware that unless you do
use a gcp tpu vm you are probably on the
old architecture
and it won't be exactly the same
experience but it's it's still
jackson tpus
right and first for some of the
questions avital also answered
i'll just anyway uh maybe read them out
to you uh
what is the difference between
grad and jit is that a question
uh the difference between grad and jit i
mean they do
different things so grad will return
the gradient function of its input and
jit doesn't take the gradient at
all it just um
returns a compiled version of the
function
and when would you not use jit and avita
answered that
you will probably always want to use jit
other than if you're debugging
okay yeah that's such a good question
something i skipped in this talk but if
you check out our documentation
um i think in the jax 101 tutorial there
is a section on jit that goes over this
um there are some constraints to using
um like you can't get literally all of
your python code and have it run faster
so yeah i think the answer is you would
always use jet
when you can but if you look at that
tutorial you'll see that sometimes you
have to
break your logic up into smaller jit
blocks um
yeah one constraint is around control
flow
um some control flow can be jitted like
if and while loops but sometimes it
can't so you can learn more about that
in the docs
that's a good question cool maybe
related to that
if you if you would only apply it to uh
primitive functions or
end to end so matrix multiplication
versus
food policy gradient updates and um
yeah probably to the entire training
step um
oh yeah so that's a good point too i
guess another situation you want to jet
is if you're just running a single
operation anyway
so like in that conv benchmark i just
showed at the end i didn't use jit
because i'm just running one operation
so yeah usually you want to get as big a
block
as you can to give xla
as much to work with as it can so yeah
it's very common for people to
jet their entire training step and then
to like drive that
from a python while or for loop
um occasionally people even jet the
entire training
loop but that can sometimes get more
complicated
uh due to the control flow constraints i
mentioned earlier
okay we have a lot of questions i i
moved down
i moved down a bit but yeah let me just
say that again
you feel free to to also post your
questions on slack
um does jax have a name tensor feature
pmap seems to be something similar but
it seems exclusive
exclusive to to map and those jacks have
a tensor annotation feature
yeah i think lv avital mentioned this in
the chat we are working on the new
x-map transform which i didn't have time
to demo this time
uh that's even more under development
than pj but yeah
the big idea there is kind of
introducing named axes in a named axis
programming model um
yeah i think we have an xmap tutorial
online if you want to learn
more about that but that is very likely
to change moving forward
is there any tool akin to nvidia smi to
see what the tpu cores are doing and if
i'm making good use of the available
memory while training
that's a great question um so there are
profiling tools for tpu
uh they're built as a tensorboard
plug-in um
again if you look at the jack's
documentation there's a page on
profiling
that shows you how to get set up with
this um so it's kind of a little heavier
weight than
nvidia smi like it's not just the
command line tool it's more like a full
profiling tool
um but that gives you like a view of
all the operations that are happening
and how long they're taking i
think that you can get a view of the
memory usage
um we definitely have that internally
and i think it works in the cloud dpu
version as well
so i would definitely check out the
tensorboard profiling plugin
and you can look at that on the jax
awesome i think we also linked to to
jack's documentation and i'll make sure
i'll share
the relevant links as well later on um i
think that's all for
for questions um for now at least
and we can move to slack thank you so
much sky this was super interesting
um and yeah thank you thanks everyone
and yeah please
i think i'll probably easiest if i
didn't answer your question to cc me
in slack because i'm not sure i'm gonna
make it through
this whole chat window that'll try it's
a lot thank you so much skye
um okay then i think we can maybe stop
sharing and
uh move on to the next talk and um
whenever mark is ready we can maybe
start sharing yes just let me
share my screen
all right can you see this yes looks
good uh though your
video we can't see your video but it's
up to you
if you want oh okay um i think it stops
okay can you see it now
looks good thanks okay
okay so let's get started um yeah so
my name is mark fonzay and i'm a
software engineer
at flex team and today i'm going to give
an introduction to flags
and so the audience for this talk is a
general machine learning interested
audience
it's a beginner's talk but it does
require some background knowledge on
basic machine learning terminology like
feed forward neural networks patch
normalization or
automatic differentiation the content of
this talk consists of three parts
um first i'm going to give a background
about flex and jacks
then um talk a bit about our ecosystem
philosophy
and then i'm we're going to go into the
flex code and look at our
main abstraction which are called the
flex modules
unfortunately i'm not going give uh
demos all the cool demos that sky gave
so uh this for me is gonna be just
slides unfortunately
okay backgrounds um yeah so flex is a
neural networking library an ecosystem
built on jacks
and we specifically call ourselves an
ecosystem
because we care about the ecosystem in
two ways
first we want to make sure that our
library has good open source support
so we have a lot of examples we make
sure our examples
run on cloud tpu we have a lot of how
to's
and also we develop with an open source
first approach and
so we develop based on github issues and
our discussions are very active
but on the other hand um we also curate
recommendations for other
libraries built on top of jacks so it's
our view that
we don't want flex to be a monolithic
library built on top of jags but rather
they should be in a collection of
libraries that work well together
so that's why we serve our users and so
we want to
guarantee that users can use other
libraries to do their projects and
i'll talk about this a bit more later
there's just some flex numbers um within
alphabet um
we're now the most commonly used neural
networking library for jags
um and we have 187 dependent projects
and
97 collaborators and hugging phase
import really a lot of flex models more
than four thousand so
um it's also nice
so um sky just gave a really great
introduction to jax
um so please take a look at that as well
but maybe people that just tuned in and
they haven't seen it i'll just have one
slide explaining jax again
um so jax people say checked is autograd
autograd and xla those are immediately
two new terms um
so autograd is like basically saying
that checks can automatically
differentiate differentiate python code
so your python functions so you can
write a python function
and there's this
this transformation called grad which is
a jax transformation and
you can pass this python function to
grad and
um jax will work great and
it will differentiate this function and
so differentiate through loops and
all kinds of things um and then jax is
also xla
so um you can you um
you can actually jit compile um your own
python functions into xla optimized
kernels
um so you do this and then because you
generally
get large computations like um sky also
explained in her talk
you give xla all the information it
needs to find the optimal way to execute
it
and then xla will optimize it
to get the best performance depending on
the accelerator
yeah so another way of looking at this
is that jax is an
extensible system for composable
function transformations
so these functions jit pmap and grad
they are all function transformations
and that means you input a function
and this function transformation will
return a new function
and an important part is that jax uses a
functional api
so it means that it only guarantees
correct behavior
when you are using or you are inputting
functions functions without side effects
um so typically side effects are the
result of mutating an object that lives
outside the function
and this functional api is a reason why
xla can do such a good job optimizing it
so here are just two example
compositions
you can adjut grad which is what you
usually do when you do standard gradient
descent
or you can v-map and grad and that is a
way to get per example gradients
um and you get it very efficiently
because if you want to do it
naively you have to use a batch size of
one which is pretty slow
okay now the world already has
tensorflow and pi
torch and and there's little need to
build a clone of either of them
um but we believe that the funk the
composable function transformation
approach that jax takes
opens up new frontiers for making neural
net code more maintainable more scalable
and
also more performance than existing
libraries
so i just listed some examples here but
there are many more
and so using jax you can write models as
single example code and you can
introduce batching automatically with
vmap
so you just input your entire uh
all your examples in one array and it
will go back to automatically
you can also automatically handle record
batches using
masking and you can create efficient
compile-time and runtime models
or remove memory headaches by uh using
easy
re-materialization or reversibility for
instance
the reformer was also based on jax
and lastly but not least it's it's
really fast um
if you there's a there's a so hugging
face recently
created a number of really amazing
scripts but they um
they train some flex models and then
they do some comparisons and they are
really fast for instance you can
pre-train bird in under 18 hours
and and using uh the cloud tpus that's
less than 150 dollars
which is which is quite quite cheap
okay so now let's just take a preview of
flags
um flex builds on top of checks and it
contains everything you need to do
your deep learning research here on the
left you see an example
um but i will talk about the code in
more detail later
so it doesn't matter if you don't get
all the details
and our main abstraction is the module
abstraction
and it's pretty similar to the
abstraction that you might know from
tensorflow and pytorch if you've used
that so
we strive to offer an api familiar to
those experienced with
those kind of libraries but flex is
fundamentally a functional system for
defining neural networks
so what i mean is that you write your
modules in a stateful or
object-oriented way as you can see in
this example and this is this is a class
which is
within with the state um
in order to operate with jax
transformations we must expose
pure pure function so like i said before
jax uses pre-order functions and we
cannot just construct
this mlp and pass it to a jax
transformation that wouldn't work
so instead we should create a stateless
or pure function
from our modules that we can use with
checks transformations
and this also allows you to compose them
like you can in jax
and therefore modules come with two
functions that you that return a state
rather than maintaining a state in it
and apply
and here you see in the example we have
an mlp a multi-layered pressure prone
that's created
and then um first you construct your
model and then
you call model.init and that is actually
how you initialize your parameters and
there you see the parameters are
returned
and they are not stored in the model and
also when you call apply the output is
also intense
so um this is this is the way we build
flex
um but alternatively you can of course
also expose stateful functions
um but then you cannot use the jax
transformations directly
so this is what other libraries for
instance objects they do that
and it also works but it's not the
philosophy you follow
okay so that's about the module
abstraction um
also our rng handling is an important
feature of
flex so
jax handles rngs differently from numpy
because numpy's rng design and so the
generating pseudo-random numbers uh it
makes it hard to to
guarantee a number of desirable
properties for doing machine learning
research um
so i won't go into the details here but
um
basically a numpy the the rngs are based
on a global state and with jax you
specifically
provide the state to your random number
generation
so in in flex the user also explicitly
provides the rngs when initializing or
applying a module
however you only have to do this at the
top level so as you see here
as an argument to the init function we
have jacks.random.prng key0
which is a which is used for creating um
for for initializing the parameters of
your model
but it only has to be done at the top
level and then flex make sure that
that this sheet is split
deterministically for all the
sub modules like in this uh this nlp you
have a few dances that are
automatically also then initialized
um so now we also have a number of
utility functions which are thin and
decoupled
um in this sense flex comes with what we
say batteries included and we have a
number of
those to simplify your workflow um but
at the same time we believe it's also a
good feature
and the dvds can bend can be decoupled
and split off into separate libraries
um for instance we recently switched our
optimizers to use
another library optics and i'll talk
about that also a bit more
later we also maintain a number of
examples and
from different domains and also talk
about a bit more later and then we have
some how-to guides and patterns
explaining some of our design choices
okay so let me now talk a bit about the
flex ecosystem philosophy
and as anyone who's ever worked with jax
is probably well aware
there have been many libraries built on
top of jacks and they usually end with x
flags objects tracks and there's just
really a lot of them
and while it can be a bit confusing we
believe that
this is essentially not a bug but it's a
feature
and we believe it's actually very
healthy to have a number of libraries
built on jacks that interoperate
and actually we we believe that this
really plays well with the
compositionality of jax transformations
that we talked about before
so what we envision as flags is
the czech's ecosystem as a set of
decoupled libraries that are each
individually well maintained
and they follow these points that we um
that we suggest
and so the first one is minimize
indirection
so we want to make it easy for users to
navigate to the low level operations in
their machine learning code
so we want to keep the control flow
relatively simple and
you don't have to pass a function that
calls a function that's called a
function or
very deep subclassing those are the
things we try to avoid
secondly we have a bias against
inversion of control we prefer
duplicating code over abstractions that
require many options
so simply put we prefer to avoid
abstractions like a trainer
and that capture common use cases and
hyper parameters in the construction
arguments
so we we actually believe that it's it's
virtually impossible to consider all use
cases
and and keep if you keep expanding
extending such abstractions
with new options that that's a road that
we don't want to go down
to and i also think that in the past
that has
has shown that this can lead to quite
confusing apis
um of course we don't want to discourage
anyone who would like to implement
something like that on top of flex
um but we as the flex team we refrain
from doing so
and the third lossly loosely corporate
libraries um
so this is comparable to the unix
philosophy so just like in unix
processes operate through streams and
functions can be piped
um that injects libraries interoperate
by passing pure functions
to each other so pure functions are the
lingua franca
and four uh yeah we care about error
messages we use slugs with uh which are
well documented
um five codes should read out the math
in the paper
it follows somewhat from the other
points but we just want to stress that
the math
is what matters there should be a few
distractions from actually this math
and then we prefer separate libraries
for separate needs
but it's more important that they are
actively maintained and supported
okay so this is an example of
what of a recent change in our in our
ecosystem
so um as flags we use these flips
which are flex which is a flex
improvement process
so if someone wants to propose a large
change then
they can create a flip and then we
discuss it
[Music]
so we think this is a good example of
healthy development so
we as flex we had our own optimizer
module which is flex
dot optim um but we always felt that it
did not work right it wasn't
it didn't really have a functional api
um
but then we found that deepmind actually
built a dedicated library for optimizers
called optics
which is based on composable gradient
transformations and it is
very functional this it uses a
functional api
so we actually believe that it works
nicer than our own optimizer so
we in during this flip um we we decided
to switch to optics
and now we recommend using flex with
optics and most of our examples
already are using optics now and also
talk a bit more about how optics work
works later in this talk
so here's um a visualization of the
jack's ecosystem that we command we
recommend as the flex team
and of course libraries we don't mention
here so it is opinionated
and we also only mention libraries that
fit our our philosophy like
and the most important thing is that
they have to work well together with
each other
and they are well maintained so at the
bottom you see um
jacks and then all the verticals that
are built on top of that so we have
flex for no networks uh op text for
optimizers and losses and then if you
want to work on special
specialized domains we have a number of
libraries um
ott for optimal transport rlax for
reinforcement learning
and jref for graph neural networks
then there's also checks to tensorflow
which is a tool that is
actually built by the checks team and
and it allows you to
to take a jax graph and to directly
convert it to a tensorflow graph
and that basically allows you to export
it to a saved model and then you can use
everything that the tensorflow ecosystem
has to offer like for serving
or for running your models on the web or
in the browser
um there's also checks for testing and
um in flexting we also have the
checkpoints that we use
and we also recommend using glue which
is
called common loop details and that is
to simplify simplify your training loop
so this is a list of some of our
examples
and um yeah if you just want to get to
know this it's nice to look through it
we started with mnist it's a very simple
example and it's just one file i think
um then we also have seek to seek which
is which uses a recurrent
neural network and lstm
with imagenet of course confnets it's
very
popular and then we have actually a few
transformer implementations
um wnt is i think our most advanced one
is also
i think based on the mlperf results so
it uses some of those tricks
and then we have pixel cnn
for generating images and we have ppo
for reinforcement learning and we have a
bunch more examples
okay so that was um about the flex
ecosystem let's now talk about flex code
and specifically flex linear modules so
in the past one one and a half year we
worked on the new
what we call the linen api so we had an
api
before that and this is kind of our our
second iteration on our api
sorry and what we did we studied all the
existing neural networking libraries
built on top of jacks at the time so for
instance tracks
objects haiku and then we try to see
what would be the best of of all these
libraries and what we what do we think
is best um
then we did a number of focus groups
with different groups of users
so for instance some users that really
like flags or people that really didn't
like it
and just to and then we iterated from
that further so what we ended up
is the linen api and i mean we believe
it's quite ergonomic and
we try to give a lot of flexibility
while avoiding food guns
and especially what we call the silent
foot guns so that is for instance that
things happen and you find out really
late
so um some of your some of the
parameters in your model were actually
changed why you didn't want them to
change they weren't mutable
or you get a nan when after training
really long and
that's that can also be apis can also be
a cause of that and we try to avoid that
as much as possible
okay so let's look at an overview of how
these models are used modules are used
so in the first step you instantiate the
module so
this module is called model uh and we're
going to look at plenty of examples
later
um so now you instantiate it and but
this will only construct
the module and not initialize any
variables because remember that we don't
want to
store the state of the parameters in the
module
then to create an issue of variables you
call model.init
and as a first argument you pass the
prng key for initializing all the
parameters
um in this presentation i probably call
parameters often params as well
but it's the same and you pass them you
pass them
the inputs of your model but when you
initialize these
inputs are only used for the shapes
then the parameters are created using
initial initialization function
that is provided when you define them
i'll show it later okay so now there's
two ways of calling applied to your
model
the first is if you have no mutable
state so this is the default case
this means that your model only contains
parameters that and they don't change
when running the forward pass
and so then the model is just going to
return outputs
and and you see with 3a there's also
that function signature
you you get the variables in and your um
input x and it just returns your output
y
now there's also plenty of cases where
you have actually a mutable state you
want to change
some of your parameters while running
the forward pass so
for instance batch normalization
now because we want to have this
functional api we cannot store this
state inside the model so we should also
return it
so in this case apply will return the
tuple and it will return your outputs
and it will chi
will return the parameters that have
been changed
a note you also should pass the mutable
keyword arguments to apply and you say
which of these of your params are which
of your variables
which collections are mutable and then
otherwise if you don't do that flex will
complain
okay now i explain these 2 3 a and 3 b
separately with some code
okay so let's define a module so this is
a module
called net that takes as input
an image and it outputs a probability
probability distribution over 10 classes
so let's start from the top
so you define model attributes in this
case units you define it as you do in
a data class so in fact flex modules are
also data classes but they are special
kind because we add an optional parent
and name attributes but you
typically don't have to care about that
now there's actually two ways of
defining modules
this is the one way is shown here and
that is you you have a function set
up and you have a function call and this
is the normal case but there's also
another way which
we call the compact way and i'll show
that later
um but here you define them in setup and
you might be wondering as a python user
why is it not just called init
and that's because data classes they
take over in it and um
that's why we use setup but you can
treat it like in it so
you just um define all your sub modules
there so in this case
in this code we have a conf net um
and we have a fully connected layer a
dense so itself.com ourselves at fc
now when you want to run the forward
pass in call
um what we do is you get the
your input x and you just run through
the confnet
then you have an activation function
then you reshape it
and then you um run it through the fully
collect
connected layer and it returns a log
softmax over your classes
so we use a number of predefined modules
here and
what you also see is that we have
automatic shape inference so
we don't make any assumptions about the
shape of x
so that will be automatically inferred
when you when you construct
when you when you initialize the model
with a specific shape
on the bottom right you see um the
parameter tree that's created
um so that's automatically created it's
just a dictionary
and um the names of these of these
parameters are the same as you
assign to self so self.com is just gone
it's just
in the parameter tree it's conf and
that's the same as as it's done in pi
dodge
okay so that's just um how you define a
number one and now i just have to hear
the comparison between
non-compact and compact so which you use
is up to you
but um let's first look at the
differences so with compact you just
have one function that you define
and you annotate it with an android
compact and what you do here
you both um create the modules and you
call them
directly after each other so you have
your nn.conf
and you then immediately apply
x to it and that's indeed very compact
um
so which one of these two you uh want to
use is up to you
um if you're using very large models it
may be
maybe you prefer using setup um
um but we really like compact we use it
all the time and we believe there's a
number of upsides so um
for instance if you have a model i don't
have an example here but
a model with loops so suppose you want
to create a number of layers then
you need this loop both in setup and in
call so that's it's a bit redundant and
if you use compact you only have to make
one loop
um and also you're collocating concerns
so everything is defined and used in one
place so
if you use the regular modes then you're
constantly switching between call and
setup and
that can also get a bit annoying and of
course come back to shorter
okay so let's now initialize a model
with model in it
okay so
here we first import jax's version of
numpy
uh as sky set jax has its own numpy um
and then we we create a random key um
and then we create a shape so inputs is
a
um has a shape and it's only once
because like i said when you call init
it doesn't matter what the value of this
is um and then you construct
and then you construct um your net
and then you call in init with the key
and the inputs and that will return your
uh your variables
um and now what i'm doing here which is
quite a nice trick
you can call jacks.tree map and which
will
apply everything to the leaves of your
tree so then if you
give it as argument for your tree you
give it the vars and as as the function
you give it gmpa.shape it will print out
the shapes of all your
your leaves so it's quite a compact way
of viewing your parameters
now what this shows is what we also saw
in the picture before so we have um
a collection params and and params is
what we use
for all these uh parameters that the by
convention are
immutable but you can have more
collections as i will show later
um and now these names are generated
automatically so before
we saw that they were called conf but
that was because you were using
um a setup and call so there you have
self.conf and it we knew it was called
conf
but in this case you're not assigning
this
conf to anything so we just generate a
name which is not based on anything it's
just a counter
but you can always assign it a name
yourself if you want to you can just use
a keyword argument to um
to conf like name is
okay now that we've created um this
module let's
call apply on it um to get the outputs
so what we do now at the top is uh is a
trick that we um
that we that we often do and that's not
a trick it's just like how you how you
deal with uh jack's random
numbers if you need a new uh uh
random key then you should split your
existing one or you just create you just
create a new one but
usually you just split it so we we in
the previous uh slide we created this
key and now you call
jackson through split and then you get
two keys back
and the last one you we just keep for
reusing and the first one is the new one
we're going to use for input and then
we just create some fake inputs of the
shape that we want
and then we call apply and
we apply it so we take our vars which is
from init
and we pass the inputs and this will run
it to the forward pass and it
returns indeed and this array for each
class it gives you a
log softmax which is of course nonsense
now because we didn't do any training
um yeah it's also a funny thing to
notice that we construct here a new net
um so basically this this is kind of
like
um maybe a good example of the of the
the fact that we don't carry state
like basically every time you you want
to go apply or in it you can just as
well create a new instance of this
this class because it doesn't have any
state except what you pass to the
constructor which is usually
um yeah some arguments from your hyper
parameters
okay um
okay so the examples before that uh i
talked about they all used um
uh params from predefined modules so we
had uh the
confnets and we had the dance and then
we saw that indeed we got this nice
param dictionary but um at some point
you probably want to create your own
params
and for this you use self.param in your
module
and so here on the left you see an
example and so now
we create a part of the dance and we use
compact
and for the kernel we use self.param
and um this this requires three
arguments so the first one is a name
which will appear in the in the dict
and the second one is the initializer
function that you will use to initialize
your um
your parameters and the third one is the
shape of the parameters that are going
to be initialized
and you see that you don't provide any
rng here
so if you remember that when we call
module.init we pass an rng
now flex will make sure that this rng is
automatically split up and
and your parameters are initialized
using that rng in the splitted way
so params are immutable by convention i
also said that before and it means that
we assume
that that you're not going to modify
them um
so you also see that so the self.program
api returns uh something that's
immutable you cannot
change it and otherwise you get an error
but that's what we talked about before
there are use cases where you maybe want
to modify the parameters
um so how do you do that well for that
you use a self.variable
i'm going to talk about that now
now a first thing to notice is that
self.variable is just a more general
version of self.param
and so basically the self. is
just a thin wrapper around self.variable
and
cell the param creates a variable of the
collection param
and with variable you can use different
collections so here um
in this case you have a cell that
variable and you have one argument more
at the beginning
which is for your batch statistics and
that will just create it uh
of that collection and give it a name
and then
uh you initialize the function and you
see here we return a mutable variable
so this r a mean dot value you're now
changing it so
you're modifying it so that's the way to
use these to create these variables
okay so um now we can again call init
and apply on this
on this variable um on this batch
normalization and now you see
i'm not gonna go throughout the details
but in batch
norm on the fourth line i think my point
was actually not working well on the
fourth line
of the yellow block um you call apply
and now you pass mutable is and you say
your bad stats are mutable
and then it also returns your mutated
first as far as the
the second element of the pair and then
we can we can see whether what is in
this mutated farce and indeed your bad
statistics aren't there so those have
are the ones that have been changed
and you can use them then as you want
okay that was a bit about internals of
modules
now for optimizer we recommend using
optics
so optx is a library for composable
gradient transformations and in these
composable transformations sound
quite a lot like checks so it probably
works well with jax and it does
so it has also very similar interfaces
flex modules
so flex uses in it and apply and opt x
uses init and update
so the way it works on the left there's
an example for standard gradient descent
you call optics.chain and then you just
pass all the
transformations you want to apply and in
this case
we use optics.trace so you can you
compute the trace of the gradient with a
decay
and then you call uptext.scale and you
scale it by negative learning rate now
once you define this chain
um you you update you you get a optic
state
by uh calling init on the parameters of
your model
um so next uh to update uh so to update
your parameters
um do this in in two steps uh first you
just call uh
update with the gradients um and the
state of the of the optimizer so again
you see
also here the state is explicitly passed
and the params of your
model and it returns updates and a new
state
and then basically the only thing uh
that optics dot apply updates does
is um it will just add the updates to
the params so the params are the
parameters of your network and the
updates are
the delta how they have to change
towards the
right way after taking the gradients
so that's the so you can also see more
of our examples they also use optics
so we use now uh in order to simplify
some of the
um some of the bookkeeping around optics
and optimizers so we use a train state
helper data class so it stores a number
of uh
of things that are very convenient so
what what is your apply function
uh the params um and then the state of
what kind of optimization you want to do
and um yeah we also use this in our
examples um
so you can also take a look at it there
but we think it makes it a bit
more verbose while not making it overly
abstract
less for both um okay so that was a bit
um
about some flex code but if you now want
to
start with coding and flex um so the
overview i
provided were more some building blocks
um so to put them together it may be
useful to just look at some
some examples and i would start with
mnist um
i also want to say that we are
completely agnostic to what data
pipeline or tokenizers or what what you
want to use
tensorflow data hugging phase data sets
doesn't matter
for us the only thing that matters is
that you end up with a numpy array
and you can pass it to a jited function
and it will still be fast and run on
accelerators
another way a nice way to get started is
look at the hugging phase
scripts so they made a number of really
nice scripts uh that uh
don't create further abstractions but
they they do demonstrate how you can
use flex um and they also have they also
implemented a number of models in flex
so that's also useful to take a look at
now here's some some things we're
working on right now
one thing that we are aware of is that
it's sometimes difficult to debug jack's
code
um also yes it sometimes just takes a
while to jit compile it that's one uh
one
uh thing but another thing is that um
because these functions don't have side
effects you cannot print
easily outputs so um we're looking at
how to how to improve that how can you
print
um debug statements from a jittered
function but also how can we
uh maybe we don't have to like jit
compile everything and it takes a long
time maybe we can already do some
analysis up front and then save
ourselves sometimes that's something
we're looking at
um yeah the hugging phase training
script they're really writing a lot of
scripts uh
so i think they have gpt2 and bird and
a lot of a lot of things um oh it's
actually going to be talk about that
tomorrow um
by the hugging face team so maybe
they'll mention that as well
yeah we're looking at more end-to-end
examples um reinforcement learning
object detections if you are
keen to to help let us know um we're
also looking at mixed precision on gpu
um this is something that um
[Music]
yeah this mixed precision is a difficult
topic and um
if you run on tp you you will
automatically run with um
half precision because dpu uses b
float16
but on gpu um this is a bit more tricky
and um
we were thinking of how to best uh we
have some examples where we do this
but there's a number of tricks and
things you have to know so we're now
writing a how-to for that
um we're also working on easier to use
public tpu examples actually that
they are now already quite in a good
state and also at multi-host
gpu training examples okay so if you
want to learn more
here are some links to documentation um
the flex basics
i think annotated amnesty is also very
useful um
because mnist is a starting example and
it just explains all the steps that you
want to do very well
we have also a number of how-to's here's
just one example um
this is an example of how to do
ensembling so you just make a few
changes to your code and
immediately you can train an ensemble of
devices
models on all the devices that you have
available
we have a number of design notes that
you might find interesting if you're
wondering why we made certain choices
um also on lifted transformations which
i didn't talk about here but um
lifted transformations are about how to
apply jack's transformations to flex
modules
and then we have a number of discussion
forums our
github discussions is pretty uh pretty
active so if you have any questions you
can just ask it there and we're always
happy to
help out so i think that is the end of
my presentation
and thank you all very much for um
listening
thanks so much mark um this was really
great i think your
and skye's talk are super super good
preparation
for um for all of the community members
that are
joining the community week next next
week and are
actively working on projects so really
really helpful
um and yeah great that we have the
recordings will be uploaded soon to
youtube
we have a lot of questions and a lot of
again really great discussion in the
chat um i think we have a few minutes
maybe let me see where we can start and
scroll back a bit
um let me start with the first ones
first ones are a bit high level
you mentioned it when you talked about
the linen api
um you studied like different kinds of
things why and what would you prefer
flex over haiku for instance
you said you're upon it yeah oh you know
i i
actually didn't mean to say we improved
upon haiku i just meant to say that we
looked at all the libraries and then
kind of made our own choice what we
thought was best
um i mean i think haiku is also a great
library and
we're actually um also talking with
deepmind about
where we have recent things where we
talk about
ways in which work together like optics
is an example of that um
so i don't think we explicitly our goal
wasn't explicitly to approve upon haiku
there were like a couple of related
questions on performance
on gpus and some like comparisons were
shared
on some links
okay um oh avital share these
comparisons
yes what's the uh question how is it
performing on gpu
if it is also faster yeah so yeah i'm
happy after shadows numbers because it
looks it looks actually really good
um i mean um yeah you can you can look
at those numbers
um so we looked at language modeling
and um text classification and there it
was actually very fast
we compared it also with pytorch um but
we have to of course say that python
was running in full precision training
so and and there's
probably many tricks you can do to to
optimize pi torch
but but this was just like a comparison
where we also didn't do any tricks to
optimize
jacks we just ran it as it is and and we
ran
by torch as it is both in full precision
and it was it was vital
actually it surprised it that it was so
much faster so we thought it was
interesting
and um yeah knowing that jax maps to
numpy someone says
would flax be in terms of level
abstractions more like tensorflow level
abstractions or
keras level abstractions in general
um yeah i mean i'm not really sure
because there's also different versions
of
of uh of tensorflow um like i said we
don't wanna
um have have our own trainer
abstractions so we wanna
have the user to have control of their
uh of their own uh
trainer training loop and we want to
have as few as practices as possible
um so then i i guess in it's if
it's close to tensorflow than keras
because keras is built on top of
tensorflow and i'm seeing it correctly
um yeah
cool we have a comment on the linen api
um yeah it's beautiful and elegant and
seeing it for the first time
really liking it so that's
thanks a lot good good feedback
uh all right what else do we have here
yeah maybe more technical questions um
let's see can you elaborate on automatic
shape in france
um does that have to do with vmap um
and this whole no no no it just no it
just means that we we do lazy uh
initialization so um
for each module and all the sub modules
uh we don't
construct anything we don't construct
any parameters
until we know the shapes of your uh of
of what your
uh what your input's going to be so um
when you call model.init you pass the sh
you pass the shapes
of your inputs and and and that we used
to derive the shapes that we need later
for all the params so there's nothing
that doesn't
have to do anything with which text
transformations it's just some just a
feature of flex
great and let's see
that's still a lot someone asks uh since
by torch will soon have bf16 support
will jax
soon too be able to run with bf16 on
gpus
um yeah i mean jax i i i think you can
um probably do it if you just set the
deep type yourself
that's also what we do in our example
but um i um
i don't know what jax's plans are there
but so we
like i said we're working on this this
how-to where we try to explain a bit
more how to do this for flags
and maybe sky can answer yes good point
darling
i don't know i just asked to a mute if
she wants to comment on that
sorry can you repeat the question
oh shall i repeat it um
since by pytorch will soon have bf16
support
will jax 2 be able to run with bf16 on
gpu
oh that is a good question um i am not a
hundred
percent sure if we support b flood 1600
gpu either
um yeah if
someone wants to post in the slack
channel or even open
a github issue um then we won't lose
track of this because
we can ask someone who will know the
answer
sounds good let's do that i think
there's like still a lot of questions to
cover
and i'm afraid we have to move to slack
but maybe
one last uh positive feedback jack's pie
tree
utility is amazing and applicable way
beyond just jack's code so
that's really great too
okay um
then i'd like to say thank you um to
mark
uh if it's okay we'll just i maybe also
save the chat history here
uh on zoom to have it later on and let
me just see if i have
muted you
oh yeah
it does seem so mark are you back
oh am i am i not muted yes you're
unmuted
it's okay sorry i muted myself so um
mike
i just want to say that my comment on on
b float 16 on gpu
was not accurate i was thinking about
float 16 so don't listen just listen to
what sky said there was
okay cool yeah as i said i think both
talks were amazing and
such good prep for for next week for all
of the projects that are coming up so
thank you so much both
uh mark and skye for your talks um
yeah yeah cool and i think it's time for
and we're like
perfectly on time look at that um let me
just quickly unmute pablo
um if i can find you
um there you go
thanks everyone for your patience i
think it should work now
uh can you hear me yep perfect
all right i'm just sharing my screen
pablo is also part of the google brain
team
and you'll be talking about dopamine and
reinforcement learning
yeah and jacksonville of course yeah
so hello everyone my name is pablo as uh
uh i'm going to be talking less about um
you know the internals of jackson flax
i'm not a jax flax
developer but i i'm a user active user
and enthusiast
so i lead the dopamine project uh in
within google which is a library for
reinforcement learning research
and uh so last year we added jackson
flac support to dopamine so i want to
talk about that a bit and and why we
made that decision
and and sort of the advantages we've
gotten from that
um okay so uh as i mentioned dopamine is
a this open source library released in
um for doing reinforcement learning
research and i know there's many of
these types of libraries around we
weren't really trying to reinvent the
wheel but
what we were aiming for um was something
that we call throwaway research so you
can imagine different research pathways
when you're doing
not just reinforcement learning research
but but in general research
so one pathway is running testing
hypotheses right so
you have double dqn which is already a
published rl algorithm
and you want to test out whether how it
how it
handles uh what policies it produces and
so you can run whatever library you like
that has uh this implementation and then
draw your own conclusions
another type of research path could be
something that's an algorithmic
variation
of an existing algorithm where it
doesn't the code changes aren't too too
severe
and you know you can implement this
pretty easily on whatever package is
available
and then you can figure out whether it's
worth continuing down this path
but the research path we were interested
in is what we call throwaway
research where you're really trying kind
of wild ideas
um that are hard to implement and
they're not that simple to just
download your the library that has has
it implemented and tweaked some things
and the the issue with this is that a
lot of most of the time most of these
will held ideas don't work and you end
up throwing it away and that's why we
call it throwaway research
um so if you have to invest a lot of
time into learning a new library and
sort of getting familiar with it
um you might not follow this research
path because it's just too much of a
time commitment
and so our intent with building dopamine
was to try to make this path
this research path um a little easier
for people
and um so really what we were building
it for research
researchers and a little selfishly we're
really building it for ourselves because
we wanted
um this library we weren't completely
satisfied with what was available at the
time so
um that's why we decided to build um
this and in the hope that it would also
help people
um which uh it seems like a lot of
people in the community have been using
it
so as i said it we wanted to experiment
easily with with wild ideas
and so at a very high level this is kind
of what dopamine looks like
originally it was just uh coded to run
on the ale which is this benchmark we
use in
in reinforcement learning um these are
60 atari games
and so this benchmark is is um where the
dqm paper the
seminal dqm paper from deepmind in 2015
this is the benchmark they used and this
is really the the paper that kind of
kicked off
the deep rl um community that that is so
large now
um so basically at a very high level we
have a runner which is what's actually
executing the
the um the running code um this is
different reinforcement learning for
those that aren't familiar
uh with it is a bit different than
standard you know supervised or
unsupervised
learning where you have a data set and
you're training off of this
this static data set in reinforcement
learning you have an agent that's
interacting with an environment in this
came
in this case an atari game and so the
data set itself is is what the agent
collects as it interacts with the
environment and so it's a little
the dynamics are a bit different and so
this is what the runners intended to do
to basically
ask the agent what action do you want me
to perform now execute it in the
environment and then log
things and checkpoint uh your parameters
so you can restore
things and but what i want to focus on
in this talk is
this these components over here so we
have our agent which is
basically what's making the decisions of
what what joystick movements to make
what actions to take
and it makes use of something we call a
replay memory which you can think of
as the data set so this is a just
basically a memory buffer
where the agent is storing all the
experiences that that it has received
from the environment and then it can
sample batches from that to perform its
learning
um and so when we originally wrote
dopamine it was in tensorflow tensorflow
version one um
and so i i what i want to do now is kind
of go through some of the pain points
that we went through in developing
dopamine
um specifically with with the version of
tensorflow that we were using at a time
so when you see this uh
this red bubble um those are the pain
points that i'm trying to highlight
okay so um i'll start with the dqn agent
which was
this uh agent that was introduced by
deepmind in 2015.
um so we have our class definition there
and when one of the difficulties that we
had
or that wasn't as easy as we would have
liked to do is in building the replay
buffer
so uh this is uh the code that's
actually building the replay buffer and
you can see it's
it has this weird name it's called
wrapped replay buffer so obviously that
suggests that it's wrapping something
else
and i'll go into a bit more details of
what that means
um so the replay buffer is not just a
memory
it's not you know first in first out or
something like that it's a special kind
of memory where you store things but
then you sample things from this memory
randomly so you have to have some type
of sampling and it also
you're filling it out as you interact
with the environment
but when during training you don't want
to start sampling until the replay
buffer is filled up to a certain amount
and it's a replay buffer that that loops
around so when you fill up the buffer
it has a fixed size you start
overwriting things at the beginning of
the buffer
and so when you add things to the replay
buffer um
the code is not completely trivial it's
not just a question of doing append
and then taking a slice so that you
maintain the same size we have to do
some logic to make sure that that we're
still
uh adding things correctly um we have to
do some padding and these are
technicalities of the way we do
this type of rl training that i don't
have time to get into now
but the sampling is is really what what
is quite uh
complex and this piece of code it's i
mean easy enough to write in
right in python but in tensorflow 1 in
order to make this run
efficiently we had to put this in graph
and so that was really hard um
we tried and it was just making the code
way too complicated for our taste
again coming back to this motivation of
of having
a library that was really easy to tinker
with and and
uh and try wild ideas on so
what we ended up doing is rather than
trying to write this in graph which was
really difficult to write and debug
we created this wrapped replay buffer
and so what this wrap replay buffer
does is it has um an internal memory
which is actually this
this other replay buffer that i was
mentioning before where you have all
this
this uh funky logic that you need and
then we wrap it
in um in this numpy function so
basically
this takes a a a python function and
makes it uh executable in graph in the
tensorflow graph
and that's how we got around this this
issue of
writing code that's easy to digest and
modify but still having things run
in graph so it's not as efficient as if
we would have written it directly in
graph but
um that was the trade-off we made in
order to be able to try out
wild ideas um so it was
it did result in more interaction it is
a bit more uh complexity because now you
have to sort of trace through
am i talking about the internal memory
or uh members of the
of the rapper class and that type of
thing so this was actually that the
replay buffer was something that we
heard a lot of feedback from people that
they found it a little difficult to
manage
on the dq and agent side um coming back
to the vqa agent again because we were
running tensorflow 1
we had to construct our training ops
prior to actually running the training
and so that's what we were doing in this
uh build train up
um so the code wasn't too complex
especially for dqn it's it's a fairly
simple
training operation but what made it
difficult is that
debugging this was hard again because
you're you're building this this
operation this up
um prior to running the training and so
if you're trying to do anything like
print debugging or using pdb
um and you do uh add a print statement
or pdb in this
in this operation here it won't work for
those of you that have worked with
tensorflow 1 you know you had to add
this tf.print
that you assigned to the same variable
you're trying to debug and it was is
a little messy i think with tf2 and
eager mode it's a lot simpler
but at the time this was quite a pain
for us to um
to debug but um we did it uh we managed
to to get it working
uh and it worked really well for two
years it's what we we were using for all
the research and it still works a lot of
people still use that tensorflow version
of dopamine um but then jax came along
and uh i i you know i started noticing
on twitter people really praising jax
and how flexible it was
um and how easy it was to to write out
complex uh operations
and and have it something that runs
efficiently but but is easy to to digest
um and this seems to to go really well
with the philosophy of dopamine of
having this flexible but powerful
um library and so i i we started working
on on uh
jack's versions of all the the dopamine
agents and so this we launched
last year um and we added an extra agent
that wasn't available in the tensorflow
code um and so i want to
kind of go through a little bit of the
steps we went to
to implement these these agents and
jacks and sort of some of the things
that
were a little not confusing but but new
for me
in the hope that it helps people in the
community get into jackson and but
also why we're still using jackson and
actually for me it's my
um tool of preference for for doing
research now i don't really use the
tensorflow versions anymore of dopamine
um one of the things i wanted to to
highlight is profiling in jax that i've
i've found extremely useful um so
basically you can
write your jax code and then run this
profiler and that allows you to
figure out where you have bottlenecks so
if something if your code is running
very slowly i've been able to find a
bunch of things where i've been able to
optimize the code
and so using the this profiling tool um
i was actually able to get the jack's
version
of of dopamine running at the same speed
as the the tensorflow
version uh one really cool thing as skye
mentioned is that
now that we have this jax version of
dopamine i can just run it on tpu
without any code changes which is not
the case uh for the
tensorflow versions so if you want to
run dopamine tensorflow on tpu you have
to
write new code which we don't have
available so that was something that was
really
appealing to me and i have run some
experiments on tpu but most of the time
we're still
training on gpu and this is mostly due
to the nature of the type of rl research
we do
okay so let's go a little bit into the
jax code and what it looks like
um so again i mentioned one of the big
pain points we had with with tensorflow
in the initial version was the the
replay buffer
um and so we have this wrap replay
buffer that we had to
uh that was necessary in order to have
this numpy function so that we could
have things in graph
well we no longer need it uh with the
jax version so with the jax versions we
can just deal directly with this
python class that we created that has
all the funky logic and there's no
indirection so that just made things a
lot simpler and easier for people to
understand and debug
on the dqm agent side we replaced this
op that we create once before we execute
the graph
with this train function so obviously
there are some
uh commonalities in the sense that um
we're jitting this as was mentioned
before so this will create a compiled
version that
uh you know you don't continue executing
but in debugging
uh what i've found really useful is i
just comment out the the jitting and
then i can actually
step through the code as you would with
with regular python um
one thing that that uh took me a couple
days of
debugging was uh that the the train
function uh
previously that all the train ops were
members of the class of the dqn class
but in jax we had to create this this
global train function
um for its work otherwise uh it was
creating weird
uh issues with with the state that i
will not try to explain because i'll
definitely do a bad job doing that
um but uh another thing where where i
spent a little bit of time is is making
sure
i get this this uh jitting uh correctly
so
um jitting as was already mentioned is
just in time compilation
and so in order to really get this
running properly you want to basically
um make sure that any arguments that are
static so for instance
um gamma which is a term we use a hyper
parameter we use in reinforcement
learning um
it doesn't change at all through
training so you can specify this as
being something static
same with the network definition once we
create the network definition which i'll
get to later
it doesn't change at all and so getting
this right really helps
speed up the the execution of your of
your
uh training um v map uh which was
already discussed this is something i
found extremely useful
um and i'll get i'll give some examples
later but basically we no longer have to
write code
that's explicitly dealing with the back
batch dimension which is something we
had to do with the tensorflow code and
that made it a lot more complex than
than we would have liked you can write
this as if it's a single example which
for some of the rl code that we use
makes things way simpler
and then you can just wrap it in a v-map
and and things kind of work
um finally one thing that at first i
thought was a little painful
but i actually have learned to
appreciate it quite a lot is that you
have to be really explicit about the
gradients and the prams that you're
using um this i
again at the beginning was a little uh
weird for me because with tensorflow
you know i just do tf.trainable
variables and send that to the optimizer
and it would do things
but uh and hopefully it's doing the
right thing but if you have you know
multi-heads or something like that and
it's not clear where the gratings are
flowing through
um i guess that they're doing the right
thing but it's a lot simpler to
introduce
uh training bugs in that way because
you're not being explicit about where
you're you're
uh making the gradients flow when you're
doing training and as
dqn is not that that complex in
architecture but when you get into
things like
software critic or something like that
where you have multiple networks that
are
sort of combined and sometimes you train
one sometimes between the other you have
to be really explicit
about where the gradients are flowing so
i really learned to appreciate this
requirement of of being explicit
um okay so i i mentioned vmap uh was
was something that that was really
useful for simplifying your code
and so i wanted to give an example um of
this
so it one of the algorithms that that we
have in dopamine
or a few of them are based on what's
called distributional reinforcement
learning
again i won't go into the details here
but basically instead of having
backing up a single numerical value for
each state in action which is how the
agent uh
chooses what what actions to take to
take um
we're maintaining a distribution of
values so this is obviously more complex
but it's a method that's proven to be
quite effective at
getting better learning performance
and so if we look one of the in the
original distributional rl papal
paper by my colleague mark delmar
one of the the way they implemented it
was having a fixed
uh distribution support so you can
imagine this like if just between
i don't know negative one and one and
you have uh a fixed number of
bins so it's a categorical distribution
um
you have to essentially when you do the
what we call the bellman backup which is
essentially computing a target
that's leveraging your previous
estimates that might end up shifting
the distribution of your values outside
of your distribution support
and so in order to make things work you
have to sort of project it back
into um your distribution support and
this is what
this all this code is doing so a lot of
it is comments but the reason they're
there is because
um we had to deal with the batch
dimension explicitly which made things
really hairy and um
again in the spirit of trying to make
this easy for people to understand we
have
a running example that showed you you
know how the the matrices are changing
where the batches
and and that type of thing um it was
pretty hairy uh to get right but uh
we managed to get it right um but it
made it was made a lot more complicated
because we had to deal with the batch
dimension explicitly and as you move
things around the batch
kind of goes into different dimensions
and you have to uh make sure you're
doing things right
um with jax uh you have something this
is it this is all the code so all those
those two columns i had before um you
you uh essentially can write it exactly
like this and so we still have comments
we're pointing to the paper
function so you can look this up but the
code is a lot tighter and the reason
it's like
it's this uh concise is because we don't
have to deal with the batch dimension
um which just make things a lot easier
so vmap for the win
okay so now i want to go a little bit
into networks that i mentioned
i wanted to talk about so up to now
everything has been jacks
for the networks we've been using flax
and and linen
um so i wanted again to give you an
example of
how uh jax flax and linen have helped us
you know make the code simpler and and
easier to use so i'm going to use
implicit quantile networks which is a
a type of distributional reinforcement
learning where instead of using uh
categorical distribution they're using a
different way of parameterizing the
distribution and i
won't go into the details here but it's
a fairly involved uh
methodology for for updating this
distribution and so the the network
itself
requires um this was done with keras
when you're creating the network you
know this isn't too too bad you just
have
three con layers and then two fully
connected layers the tricky thing comes
when you're actually
um trying to do the forward pass in this
network because again you have to deal
with uh with the batch dimension here
um because this is this uh iqn is a
little involved
um you have to explicitly be aware of
where the batch dimension is and sort of
fold it into these operations carefully
so that it
so that it works well and this actually
took us quite a bit of time um to get
right
um one thing we do uh with dopamine is
have unit tests for everything so that
that helps us
um you know validate confirm to
ourselves that we're doing the right
thing and also for the community to know
it helps it's a form of documentation in
itself
okay so this is the keras code um again
batch set
the batch dimension made things really
complicated with jax we have something
like this so we no longer have to
uh create the network and then have a
special um way of dealing with batch
dimensions when we're doing the forward
pass
we can just use the uh the compact
decorator of linen
and um specify our network again it's
just three comp layers with two fully
connected layers
and then the the complex iq and
operations uh we can code them up as if
we don't have a batch dimension which
just makes
makes things a lot easier um to deal
with
again the map for the wing um so i want
to come back
again uh just before finishing the talk
to the street i had where
um we really felt that uh jax the the
philosophy
of jax and and flax and and all of this
this community is really about
enabling flexible research but without
necessarily sacrificing uh
efficiency and this goes really well
with with the dopamine philosophy
and so um i just wanted to highlight uh
two recent papers
that that we have out um that that
were really enabled by by jack so a lot
of the experimentation we did there
um was non-trivial and it was made a lot
easier
um by the use of jacks and flax and then
so the first one on the top revisiting
rainbow this for those of you
um that will be joining icml we're going
to be presenting this at icml
um and the bottom one we put this up on
archive recently this is using
state metrics to uh learn better
representations for
rl and this paper in particular the the
operations of doing this the state
metrics for presentation learning
is pretty involved and i think it would
have been a lot more i know it would
have been a lot more complicated to do
this
in with the tensorflow versions of
dopamine um so
there's other stuff that uh
unfortunately i can't share with you
because we haven't made it public yet
that's even wilder and hopefully we'll
we'll be able to share it soon and and
really
i think uh part of the reason why we're
trying out these wild ideas a lot of
them are working quite well
is because of the flexibility that jax
and flax enables so with that
um i'm glad i'm done a bit early so if
there are any questions i know
i really had to skim over the rl details
um i just kind of wanted to give a high
level overview of an end user of jax
flax
and um how how we uh how this has
enabled
even more flexible research so again
check out the the repo
um we're actually actively working on it
right now uh and it's sort of a spring
cleaning of sorts even though we're
already
technically in summer uh but we'll be
sharing some new updates and some new
goodies that i think the community will
like quite a lot
um so stay tuned to that
awesome thank you so much pablo i really
like it um
you know having the flexibility and
yeah to try out wild ideas wild research
ideas that's always a good thing
cool we do have a few questions actually
you mentioned
maybe again like a very high level
question you mentioned
um the tensorflow versions compared to
jax you mentioned tf
one how how is it compare tf1 was
without
eager execution how does it relate to
tf2
um good question uh unfortunately
dopamine right now is not yet tf2
um it's uh so
dopamine is not my 100 job
so i'm a researcher as well so a lot of
my time is spent
just doing research and writing papers
and things um
the team has sort of shifted not shifted
but fluctuated the number of people that
are actively working on dopamine
uh so we've sort of had to leverage you
know 20 percenters and things like that
to help us out and there was somebody
that was working on the migration to tf2
but that person person unfortunately had
to shift to
different priorities so it's still
something we have there um
my impression is is uh from some
experiments we've run is
we won't get too many more gains than we
already have uh
switching to tf2 with eager um the
performance will be
roughly about the same as what we have
with tf1 and as i showed like
that performance is basically the same
as what we have with jax
and uh you said that you mainly work on
gpus with dopamine
and someone asked if there is a
multi-gpu support multi-node training
out of the box
yeah that's a good question um we have
looked into this and we did have
an internal version that we were trying
out with distributed training
with multiple gpus the difficulty here
is it's not
as simple as as just running the same
code and training it or the same
algorithm and training it on multiple
gpus when you switch to the multi-gpu
setting
your algorithm changes so you have to
deal with now you're dealing
what does it mean to have multiple gpus
well if you're doing learning in
parallel
you know there's algorithmic choices
that you have to make about how you
combine
the gradients from from the parallel
learners if it's just the actors
interacting with the environment
that's a single step they're all taking
which can speed up things if you're
doing
things in parallel but you know how do
you
combine all this data again it's an
algorithmic choice
um the reap do they each have their own
replay buffer uh what size is that
or is it a centralized replay buffer so
there's a lot of algorithmic choices
that end up
changing the algorithms that we're using
and because most of us what we're doing
is is what we call fundamental
reinforcement learning research where
it's
i'm really starting from the
mathematical foundations and building up
into the deep rl setting um moving into
these distributed settings although that
you can train things a lot faster
it's harder to maintain the connection
with the theoretical results that we
develop when we're building
when we're developing algorithms um and
and for the distributed
setting there's also other teams at
google that are doing this really well
like acme
and things like that um so again the
intent is not to have
a library that suits all types of
research we're really
focused on this one type of research
which is the the wild exploratory ideas
obviously you can't try wild ideas with
distributed studying with dopamine
because we don't support that but um
you know it's a trade-off that that
we've decided to make
um there were a few questions on
distributional reinforcement learning
um yeah just like your your view on it
if you could share some resources i
think somebody
uh shared like a paper by deepmind
just a general distributional
perspective
the the original paper that i mentioned
here which has the
um the distributional um
the distribution is parametrized as a
categorical distribution and this is the
paper that introduced
distributional rl um there's been a
number of
uh follow-up papers so iqn that i that i
mentioned
um i'll add the link here in a bit
i don't know if there's uh yet uh
survey uh
of the these types of methods um more
and more
it's uh becoming kind of standard um so
rainbow if you if you know of uh the
rainbow paper
um this part of one of the main
components of the rainbow algorithm
was uh distributional rl um
and i think the the original paper does
a pretty good job at uh
explaining it i mean it's pretty
mathematical but i think that really
builds it up from the foundations up and
and
exemplifies how it can help in deeper
altering
nice thanks so much um let's see
maybe one last question could you
maybe repeat again the benefits of remap
compared to tensorflow
yeah so um with tensorflow so
part of the reason why we we are able to
now train these these
big models in nrl um so 10 years ago
uh we weren't doing this we were running
on grid worlds and so very small toy
environments
um and what allows us to and deep
learning in general what has allowed us
to grow these networks
is um training with specialized hardware
like like gpus and tpus and things like
that where you can
run operations in parallel
so this means that you're no longer
using a single
example for instance for rl we sample
transitions from a replay buffer
um in the old days what we do is just
look at a single transition
and use that to update our our uh
estimates of the value function
um so single update that's fine for for
small
domains but if something in something
like atari it's pretty inefficient
and so what we do is we store things in
a replay buffer and then we sample
batches from the replay buffer
so that means if you think of these
transitions as being a vector
now you have a matrix right where the
the rows are the the batch
um indices um so in tensorflow the
difficulty with this was that
because we're receiving a matrix and a
lot of the operations that we're doing
they're matrix operations but they they
end up
sort of mixing um the indices so you
don't always keep
the batch dimension as the first
dimension of your matrix
you have to be really careful with with
doing reshaping and and things like that
and so
uh i mean there's tons of memes about
the these shape mismatch errors
um and that's something we face a lot
because uh we are doing these
these uh complex matrix operations um
and we have to make sure that we're
always keeping the batch dimension where
it should
be um with with the map we can kind of
code things the way we would we would
have coded things uh back in the old
old days where we only had a single
example which is a lot easier to deal
with because now you're
you're only dealing with a vector as
opposed to a matrix and so we can
write our code in that way um so we
don't have to worry about the batch
dimensions or where it is because that's
not
a thing in our code and then we just
wrap it with a v map
and um it sort of handles the batch
dimension uh transparently for us and so
it just makes the code a lot easier to
write
and and read